ahora vamos a hablar de la estructura
celular del hueso podemos pensar que el
hueso está formado principalmente por la
matriz social y por las células que de
hecho ayudan a formar la matriz ósea la
mayor parte del hueso está formado por
la matriz ósea que consiste en dos
bloques de construcción principales el
primero de ellos se llama este hoy de
este forma la parte orgánica de la
matriz también tenemos algo llamado
hidroxiapatita que forma la parte
inorgánica de la matriz ósea hablemos
primero de la porción orgánica de la
matriz ósea mencioné que esta parte está
formada por usted hoy de qué consiste en
una estructura suave pero sumamente
ordenada de proteínas y de colágeno
específicamente de colágeno tipo 1 la
orientación conjunta de estas fibras
ordenadas de colágeno y de las proteínas
ayuda a darle al hueso su resistencia a
la atracción la resistencia a la
atracción significa que si imaginamos un
pedazo de hule muy duro como una goma de
borrar hecha de hule la resistencia a la
atracción
sería algo parecido a la forma en la que
la goma se mueve ligeramente cuando uno
la empuja pero sigue manteniendo su
forma así podemos imaginar la
resistencia a la atracción del hueso
ahora la parte inorgánica del hueso la
parte inorgánica del hueso está formada
por hidroxiapatita voy a escribir su
fórmula química aquí es calcio junto con
fosfato y agua básicamente la
hidroxiapatita son cristales de fosfato
cálcico estos cristales de fosfato
cálcico son la parte mineral del hueso
lo que le da al hueso su fuerza de
rigidez y su densidad ahora que
comprendemos mejor la porción oste hoy
de orgánica de la matriz ósea y la
porción hidroxiapatita o inorgánica de
la matriz ósea vamos a hablar de las
células que son las responsables de
formar esta matriz ósea hay cuatro tipos
diferentes de células en los huesos con
las que nos tenemos que familiarizar el
primer grupo son las células osteo
progenitoras o osteogénesis luego
tenemos los osteoblastos
luego los posteos y tos y finalmente
tenemos los osteoclastos podemos ver que
todos comparten la misma raíz osteo que
significa hueso hagamos más espacio para
hablar de cada uno de estos tipos de
células primero tenemos las células
osteo progenitoras estas células son
básicamente las precursoras de los
osteoblastos son una versión inmadura de
los osteoblastos se diferencian como
osteoblastos bajo la influencia de
varios factores de crecimiento esto nos
lleva a los osteoblastos estas son las
células responsables de sintetizar tanto
el colágeno como las proteínas
específicamente un par de proteínas
llamadas osteocalcina y osteopontina y
juntas forman los hostiles los
osteoblastos también son responsables de
producir fosfatasa alcalina que es la
enzima responsable de formar la
hidroxiapatita o la parte mineral del
hueso una vez que los osteoblastos han
sintetizado suficiente colágeno
proteínas y fosfatasa alcalina para
formar la parte órgano
en orgánica de la matriz o sea alrededor
de ellos y se encuentran rodeados por
esto ellos maduran para convertirse en
este ositos así que la versión madura de
un osteoblastos una vez que ha terminado
de sintetizar la matriz ósea se vuelve
unos trocitos
esto nos lleva a los socios hitos los
espacios que ocupan los posteos hitos
dentro del hueso se llaman lagunas y
este término realmente se refiere al
espacio vacío dentro del hueso si
observamos con un microscopio estos
espacios que parecen pequeños lagos
recordaríamos que esas son las lagunas
son pequeños espacios vacíos dentro del
hueso
estos dos trocitos tienen pequeños
brazos o ramas que les ayudan a
comunicarse con otros socios hitos u
osteoblastos lo que les da esta
apariencia como de estrella estas
pequeñas ramas son como sensores que
recogen información envían señales y
básicamente permiten a los dos trocitos
comunicarse con otras células y ayudar a
mantener al hueso el tipo final de
células son los osteoclastos los
osteoclastos
de unas células llamadas monocitos y son
responsables de la resorción ósea
básicamente descomponen el hueso y lo
hacen mediante una enzima que se llama
fosfatasa ácida resistente a tartrato
los osteoblastos ayudan a construir el
hueso con una enzima llamada fosfatasa
alcalina y los osteoclastos ayudan a
descomponer el hueso de nuevo con una
enzima llamada fosfatasa ácida
resistente al tartrato básicamente el
hueso es remodelado continuamente
construido con osteoblastos y
descompuesto por osteoclastos el
osteoblastos construye el hueso y el
osteoclastos destruye el hueso ahora
conforme los osteoclastos reabsorbe en
el hueso comienzan a formar espacios
vacíos en el hueso y como se llaman los
espacios vacíos en el hueso se llaman
lagunas la cuna e iu así como los otros
hitos ocupan las lagunas los
osteoclastos ocupan un tipo especial de
lagunas que se llaman lagunas de hauché
que son pequeños huecos
2 por los osteoclastos cuando
descomponen el hueso que los rodea